this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
all right let's do this man Eddie Wong
what up what's up Brothers for having me
man appreciate you coming man yeah no I
love the Pod you're in the you're in the
podcast game now because you and your
girl started a pod yeah yeah it was kind
of like uh yeah she she you know I moved
around here from New York to LA and we
would when we beefed she would just go
like stay in the other bedroom
weird dude yeah you gotta have another
bedroom yeah no so we got another
bedroom you know for the days we don't
get along yeah but I was like this is
weird I start looking it up online and
like it's actually like a thing and I
was like you know I wish there was like
a relationship pod to talk about weird
[__] oh that's dope separate bedrooms
possible so it was your idea to launch a
podcast like let's air out our fights
yeah yeah because like she noticed she's
like yo you learn from talking yeah and
like I have to talk [__] out and be
wrong and argue and then I'm like oh I
figured it out then you come back yeah
that's like that yeah so I think we're
all I think guys are that way yeah you
know like like so what do you what do
you think you guys fight about the most
like wait what ethnicity is she she's
like Greek Italian okay identifies more
Greek okay yeah okay yeah different
you're in more New York how what do you
how do you look at your culture more New
York culture more I I mean I'm
definitely Chinese so I would feel like
I think being Chinese is the like he
says with his New York accent you know
yeah most representative but yeah
honestly I don't really I never fit in
anywhere when I think about you I think
New York yeah yeah I definitely became a
man in New York and identified the most
with being a New Yorker yeah more than
even my race but I'm like I look Chinese
because I'm 41 now so don't think about
it as much but you're right I would I I
think I would say I identify most with
New York New York yeah it's just one of
those things once you live in LA you try
not to think about it too much because
you're just like [__] I want to move
home oh yeah yeah yeah like me and my
girl talk about it pretty much probably
once a day like how much longer you
think we're gonna be out here really are
you guys getting the itch yeah but now
we have a kid she just popped a kid out
how old weeks ago oh damn your dad yeah
I like the way and he talks about I
moved her out here from New York got a
separate bedroom yeah
get out two weeks ago man he's like a
chef yeah to his core get the food to
the customers now you know yeah
fire baby two orders bacon yeah you got
no time I can tell you what your wife
gets mad at you about you probably have
no sentiment at all let's get this done
how much is this honeymoon gonna cost
let me break it down
like when you mix a kid in like you guys
better be a team man like yeah that's a
different animal no it's for sure we
definitely a team but she's gonna love
this pod because that's probably what we
beef about is like I can be emotionally
detached the same time without knowing
it so can we all yeah like I A lot of
times you get in trouble for the tone of
your voice yeah or it's my delivery
she's like I'm not I'm not one of your
podcasts like don't talk to me like
they're like that's how I talk
that's me from day one today just today
uh my wife is not talking to me because
I woke up at five and I could woke up at
four in the morning couldn't sleep as
usual
just the world and my son they made a
lava lamp and you need you use water and
oil they're miserable my one and a half
year old got into the oil and just
walked everywhere so it's all over the
floor of the oils all over the hardwood
floor the way you get rid of it is you
put flour down yeah it's tough to get
off yeah
last night I wake up I put flour
everywhere I rub it into the floor I
vacuum it up I I then I sweep it up then
I gotta clean up I'm up till it's an
hour at least and then she had kind of
left a lot of the stuff out because the
baby went down so I had to clean that
stuff up so I cleaned the whole kitchen
up I go back to bed
as I'm leaving she says to me I'm
already pissed because I gotta I gotta
fly to New York we got Vegas in the
weekend I just don't want to be away
from home yeah so I'm already on edge
and she says as I'm living she goes
thanks for giving me the an hour of
cleanup now that you're you've done your
thing in the kitchen
because I had I had the vacuum cleaner
was full of that oil and oh she has to
clean all that out but also that's all I
needed be cool and I went an hour to
continue you're talking about an hour
because I just I just spent an hour from
four to five and I went off yeah and the
baby's like man yeah that's smart that's
good especially when I can't when I have
to go right away and I go I'll see you
later though enjoy the hour yeah give
her a double thumbs up yeah you can't do
the [__] no you don't do the double
thumbs right don't do that no have a
good day no no I kept calling her that's
like you're not gonna sleep for three
days yeah yeah that's it I get mad and
then I'm I'm done she was like really
all right I'll just hold on to this
[__] Grudge oh I'm like Tom Brady
after interception I get over it fast
I'm sorry baby I didn't mean that I
didn't mean you got man you got Brady
mental interception I bet whatever at
work I'm like you I get in trouble for
the way I say things not what I'm saying
yeah usually it's like not wrong it's
the way I'm saying it my delivery's bad
my delivery Is Not Great emails my
agents like was literally like dude your
emails are so brutal like what's wrong
with them he's like there's no contact
your text and emails are rude you do it
to me because it's straight to the point
yeah it's a text but as we talk in
person I might deliver it different oh
we'll start yeah we'll start texting and
it starts getting sour yeah and I I we
call you halfway you have to call I'ma
pick up the phone guy because I also
don't like to repeat myself and so
emails I'll get caught up I'll just like
please refer to like September 7th
but even that it works with dudes that
does not work with your wife yeah no and
so so I don't no I don't I don't do when
I get in trouble with my wife it's not
my delivery because I know my delivery's
whack so I'm on it with her right but
what she usually gets mad at me and
she's probably right like in retrospect
she's right is like all all say
something or I'll suggest something that
doesn't take into account how it's gonna
[__] her [__] up yeah I'll be like this
is a good idea it'll work it'll solve
the problem for me but but like you
create a prom for your wife yeah and
she's like really that's the solution of
it oh my bad but by the time I realize
it and try to correct myself she's
already mad and so I'm just like yo babe
I don't mean it I just learn by talk I
have to say the bad idea to know the
good ones well that's that's good that
you're at least admitting to that yeah
she's a dime piece by the way oh thanks
man where'd you see her dude why are you
looking at this girl man bro I just saw
her
look at her right now also the breast
milk is incredible sweet good for your
health good for you put it in your
coffee and [__] yeah yeah you know I'm
saying that with great you've been with
her you've been with her for how long
for two years two years yeah yeah things
went pretty fast right yeah that's good
though listen man you can cook yeah did
you did you did you ever see a show on
Vice yeah that's how I got to introduced
you because you and my boy Maddie was on
there yeah yeah Maddie's my guy I love
Matty's the best hilarious yeah just
cooked from his cookbook this week he's
the best brother yeah because he's the
best cooking is like a way into a girl's
heart man yes or no yeah I think so I
think so and guys yeah I mean it's
usually yeah 100 guys I'll date you
right now I definitely think being a
good cook at home is the way you keep a
shorty but I think when if like she
didn't want any of that stuff up front
like our first date was a zenku chicken
because she's like I think her mentality
is like my game's too tight for that
[__] like you better show me who you
really are yeah because if I tried to
take her to nice places and flex like oh
yeah they you know we get some free [__]
here they know us or I'll cook you this
dinner she was like I'm all right let's
like just like do something chill yeah
get rid of all the fluff and stars like
let's let's get down on the Nitty Gritty
yeah well that's a good sign because she
she's looking at you to get serious
this guy for real because I could see
myself with him yeah up front she just
like didn't really go for any of the
[__] I was like damn I'm gonna have
to [__] change my name yeah
you're not impressed with my chicken you
know that's a weird thing for a dude
though because like so much of how we
identify is what we can do like so you
might be into that guy who's like really
good looking and really rich but I I at
least I'm funny honestly I'm making
things like fighting you know what I'm
saying like you got your [__] you want
to get to but some Fighters you fight
you you know what like you know what I'm
gonna have to take this yeah I may have
to do something mix it up dog yeah can
your girl cook me my girl can cook her
ass off you know but I mean she's not a
chef but she like last night she made me
this crazy pesto pasta that was so good
like she can do that she can cook
seafood like she cooks things that she
likes she's Italian you said pesto and
uh she comes from a tradition of that no
no pesto she can cook her ass on me she
bought a crab the other night
she brought home these clams she can
make crazy crazy uh crab cakes and stuff
shrimp cocktails off the chain
at least
you know what she gets mad at me dude
her rotisserie chicken well she doesn't
she doesn't cook for me because I'm
picky so what I'll do is I'll be like I
she gets so mad because she'll be
cooking I'll come over and go you know
you shouldn't you might be overcooking
that you might want to and she's oh yeah
no I [__] go to the panties yeah
especially because you can't cook oh my
God leave it up to me yeah I'm just like
I don't I have very specific taste buds
and I'm always wrong my girl can cook
her took her ass off was just only
Mexican food oh like hardcore it's fly
unless you want to stay in shape oh
that's true yeah would you wear an adult
diaper yeah dude
dude I'll come over I'm like are we
trying to [__] our pants every night
yeah but she's used to it I'm not what's
your what's your what's your go-to
what's your favorite thing what's your
favorite food or are you just one of
those you know honestly at home I just
love making a good steak like it's so
hard to get a good steak I just like to
get a nice piece of steak sear it on one
side real hard in a cast iron pan finish
it in the broiler pretty much you know
five minutes and then three minutes same
now now every guy has their their steak
that they cook I'm going to give you
mine I want you to hit me with what you
think you I've had your steak you'll
Grill it I'm a Grill Master Okay that's
that's all I can do girl I can't miss
anything else so so I'm gonna give you
what I do you tell me also Grill Master
take it easy yeah it's I mean it's good
but yeah I'll take I would love to try
it yeah first you got to get the right
cut right you gotta I like a New York
that's everything like that you know rib
eye
and then Costco actually has good Cuts
right I [__] with Costco man thank you
they're fillets off the chain thank you
I mess with their fillets not too fast
they got a good my dad be cop in the
ribeye cap at Costco yeah I'm very
familiar with their products
I'm a member so if you guys need in let
me know I was doing the whole food [__]
and that's your house payment you buy
three steaks and it's 50 70 or whatever
then you go to Costco and you can get
like you know yeah so I'll I'll take it
out get it at room temperature
salt pepper then I put dehydrated garlic
flakes on it I put it in the Traeger for
40 minutes 20 minutes at 220 so I smoke
it oh then I get the then I get a
skillet I get it hotter than the sun
don't act like this is new to you don't
be like I get it
no he's lost graduated garlic
oh wow wow you apply heat yeah it's cool
I'll do this oh you know it's some
[__] in our heads the two white boys
this white dude's [__] it up already
oh wow wow wow that is that was fun dude
I thought he had I thought I knew it was
[__] I thought I had him oh no even
I smelled it you read that oh man I was
like damn I'm impressed I was like don't
entertain this because I won't put
anything on it besides salt and pepper
okay I used to go you took my wheels off
I'm not telling the rice but it's all
right you put it in the trigger for 40
minutes forget it reverse smoke seared
it yeah and then you get a hot pan and
then you're gonna see her right reverse
smoke doesn't work yeah yeah I've never
heard smokes here yeah yeah one of my
dogs a lot of people like the reverse
here meaning like you know you roast it
slow cook it or cook it real slow and
then sear it to finish you know people
like to sous vide it and pick it up I'm
old school I I like uh I just cast iron
pan butter you know I seared the steak
and butter yeah yeah and and just either
good kosher kosher salt flake salt
cracked black pepper that's it sit it
down there
five minutes on high on each side just
on one side yeah get it to like medium
medium high when your butter is melted
and then put the steak down because you
don't want the butter to like smoke up
so medium high and then cheat to High by
the end of the five minutes immediately
going to the broiler like 550 super high
right up there three minutes steak's
done really nice so what about the other
side that isn't you sear both sides oh
so when you're going in the broiler the
Heat's coming from the top guys so then
you're banging it from the top and when
I take it out to finish because it'll be
more pale on the top I'll flip it and
then serve it the seared side up damn so
people never need to see that on the
bottom side it's a little more pale but
that way you get a perfectly cooked
steak and when you flip it and you're
letting your meat rest it will get that
finishing sear on the pale side because
I'm gonna take a little break you know
me do I gotta get my black Buffalo
yep yeah wintergreen's my favorite dude
I like this one's freaking empty that's
how much I use Wintergreen but I go with
fish straight too because you used to
dip a little bit back in the day right I
used to dip some chalk yeah this is why
I like this I did two and this is the
closest thing I can get to the the chalk
flavor those original flavors
wintergreen's my favorite I like the
straight back those long cut pouches
made for
good for green leaves
yeah fatty yep they both got uh with and
without pharmaceutical grade nicotine is
that what we're talking about obsessed
dude and if you're 21 or older you and
you use nicotine or tobacco check out
the award-winning tobacco alternative
black Buffalo I swear by these guys
people at the show skank Fest five of
them in your cheek up non-stop I go
through at least a camera blood orange
flavor or Peach they do Daddy they got
that stop it but that's why I like these
because this they don't have the the the
fruity all the fruity stuff it it
reminds me of back when I used to really
chew that's why I like it no tobacco
leave for stem right yep okay
that's good
I love it I like that absolutely they
sell will they sell their products I
mean ship their products directly to
your front door that's what I want to
know all you gotta do is go to
blackbuffalo.com that's it we can mess
around and I mean they're all over the
United States but I just go to
blackbuffalo.com come straight to the
door I got you okay all right I use the
straight pouches the straight pouches
long cut or just the pouches just the
pouches okay I want to go long cut do it
dude I just like the sound your teeth
look sweet with that yeah long cut black
Buffalo and where's your obsession with
cooking come from from your mama yeah
you know what it was I grew up in
restaurants but my dad was like yo
Chinese restaurants you don't make
enough money but steak he's like this
[__] is super easy you buy like an
expensive piece of meat throw it on the
grill give people broccoli potato you
could like you can make mad bread he
like studied Steak and Ale because he
was a waiter there and uh so he was
successful opened a couple steak houses
but when I left home I didn't miss my
dad's food I missed my mom's so I would
just like call my mom on the phone and
like cook her dishes when I was like in
college because I lived off campus and
[__] so classic Chinese classic Chinese
food and I started to write it down and
I realized a lot of the other Chinese
kids my generation and age were not that
interested in doing Chinese cooking oh
interesting yeah so none of them knew
how to make it so when it was like the
Lunar New Year party at the school it
like I wouldn't know how to do it and I
just started to cook Chinese New Year at
my house when you say Chinese food
though like what is the are there
certain core ingredients to Chinese food
yeah like like you got a mirepoix with
French food you know it's like celery
onion carrot you know garlic that's like
mirepoix I would think every single
Cuisine has its own so if it's Chinese
you have like anise and fennel and
Sichuan peppercorn and chili garlic
scallions Ginger I think those are the
most used spices if you were to like get
a fistful and be like that's Chinese
cuisine I would say it's right there wow
that's so interesting yeah and so French
would be that Chinese would be that so
every every every Cuisine has that
handful of ingredients Staples yeah yeah
Middle Eastern is the lemon and garlic
and yeah and then Arabic seven spice
like you know so things yeah that kind
of stuff that would be their mirepoix
because they utilize it across the board
Mexican you're gonna use a lot of cumin
salt black pepper onion garlic and then
you got yeah you guys have so many like
Mexican your wife would know this is
like there's just so many different
types of peppers yes and I feel like
just by using a different pepper
completely changes the dish there are
different peppers I know there's white
pepper and black pepper there's so many
ghosts they got so many peppers and then
where did the fame come from you're just
doing your thing cooking and then when
did you burst on the scene it has to be
tough as a chef like to get noticed yeah
so many chefs yeah I think really what
it was was that like you know I had this
restaurant called Bauhaus in the Lower
East Side in Manhattan and it was just
unlike any other restaurant at the time
um not many people were making bows at
that time like David Chang had become
very popular Mouse and Momofuku but no
one was doing Bauhaus in the like
authentic Taiwanese style about where
was it on Rivington Street 137 yeah yeah
yeah right across from a life yeah so
yeah yeah that's the 14th Street but um
we popped on Rivington because really
I was like I want to run a restaurant
like a skate shop so we would play
mixtapes like this is when Black Wall
Street mixtapes Dipset mixtapes clips
and restaurants weren't playing music
like that so you made it cool yeah we
made it cool and and that it's right
there the one uh on the third one fifth
one over this one yeah that's the one
that's the original restaurant that's
when everyone started to come down there
it was just Word of Mouth that got up we
got out yeah the next door was a nail
and eyebrow threading salon down the
street was a life and a basketball court
but it was just Word of Mouth like
people in New York uh they would come
here to pregame and then afterwards we
stayed open late so you get drunk just
come down eat some food yeah that's
amazing man and then and then when who
whose idea was it for the vice show
how'd that come about so what happened
was I was at the Cooking Channel I had
like a show at the Cooking Channel they
offered me like a bunch of Seasons
called cheap bites and was that dope it
was it was really good it well I mean it
was I
yeah yeah I did like one it was a one
hour backdoor pilot rated very high they
were like yo let's do this full seasons
and somebody in one of the meetings goes
yo you could be the Asian hip-hop Guy
Fieri you could sell mad pots and pans I
was like well I love Guy Fieri yeah but
like I don't want to be guy fiery like
if that's what y'all are about to do I
gotta get out of here yeah he's cool I
don't want his life yeah yeah why
because I literally can't have that many
rings on my hand like
I love him like I love guy that he's
he's him yes I'm I'm just like you gotta
do your own thing yeah I want to do my
own thing and I could tell that they
were just looking for the next Guy Fieri
and I was like that's yo let him be him
he's he's illest and then what happened
was I told my agent I was like yo I
don't think I could do this [__] and
he's like I I heard Vice is trying to do
like food stuff you should like do their
show Chef's night out and they actually
it was like coincidental my agent was
saying to do it and I got an email from
Vice like literally that was cool so I
was like oh I really believe in signs I
agree so I was like cool let's do this
especially when you're being honest like
that's a really interesting thing you
said because
you know it's very tempting to be the
next guy fury because the money is worth
a lot of money yeah right and you were
like you you I understand that I
understand that feeling like that says a
lot about you though because there are
certain things maybe as a chef or maybe
who you are just you just can't do
especially in the chef's game to make it
it's like a comic man there's so many
that stick out it's tough yeah but you
but yeah you you do it by staying true
to who you are and what you can do and
you also don't want to copy people like
that's him like he did that Dino drivers
and Dives one of the best food shows
ever ever and I'm like yo let people
like if that's his Lane let him do that
I'm gonna create my lane and so I just
you know I did this episode on Vice
introduce people to soup dumplings and
how to like put them in a sauna and it
just popped like from that episode
and vice was killing it back then yeah
yeah killing it you know it's a shell
now
yeah you don't want me on that same
thing black and those guys who got
pushed out it's a Camping World
submarine at this point
talk a little bit about the fact that I
always say that you know when we talk
about race people I say well you know
this people have but the Chinese the
ethnic Chinese correct me wrong suffered
no shortage of discrimination I'm old
enough to remember when it was so
blatant and obvious and almost
acceptable and you come from a culture
where frugality family and work yeah and
work like people think like you know 12
hours is a lot of time not to not to an
ethnic Chinese family yeah like that had
to have played a huge role in your work
ethic
no no no like I definitely think all of
our identities have like an immense
impact on who we are I don't think it's
determinative like if you're from this
community you're gonna act this way or
like if you're from this community your
work ethic is going to be ass you know
like of course I don't think it's true
but for me I would say my Chinese
parents definitely had a huge influence
on me and I even at work now still have
to undo some of the like expectations
they had because my engine's just crazy
like you know I met somebody yesterday
with an idea for like a documentary and
I immediately like made the deck last
night and he's like what and I was like
yeah I thought it was a good idea he's
like wait you did the whole deck and I'm
like yeah why not it was a good idea
these white boys take eight weeks bro I
made the deck in an hour and a half yeah
and like how was that instilled in you
example or like I I I I don't it's I'm
with him a little bit on this it's it's
weird to say that it's a Chinese thing
cultural thing yes 100 of cultural
things for sure but that but there's
also there's white people there's black
kids I know who are the exact same
thing
overlap but you but you cannot there's a
lot of people in people in China who are
very lazy but you can't cannot maybe
sleep in Ikea yeah yes but what you
cannot take out the fact that there are
certain cultural practices that might
make one group more effective in the
21st century I wouldn't discount you
what I'm what I would say is I don't I
totally see expectations maybe yeah
expectations is it I I think that
immigrants from any country your parents
are going to be pretty hard on yes right
and there is a consensus I think in the
Asian community that like
school work is important the work ethics
and all the things they're saying but
some of us Fall by the wayside some of
us follow it like you know I I haven't
always been a model minority a model
citizen but I just happen to work hard
but I think what this should I do that I
don't work hard on like not now but back
in the day like when I was an attorney I
didn't work that hard I just stayed late
so that they would pay for my dinner
I love you I love that and he went
through [__] law school though it's
like when I was an attorney oh wait you
were that I forgot before this so that's
that's a lot of work it was a lot of
work but I I hated doing it you know I
was a lazy attorney hey bro you went to
you went to law school and you were a
lawyer for two years I think the reason
why I'll like meet somebody and then go
home and I'll write the script in a few
days or write the deck really fast is
because I still feel like that kid where
the only way I touched movies as a kid
was like going to Blockbuster the only
way I touched music was like reading The
Source magazine and like getting CDs and
[__] felt so far away like even in New
York I was always like damn I would love
to move there that would be so able to
like go to these shows guys see photos
of like concerts in The Source magazine
and I think I still have this mentality
of like you got one shot like on that
stupid bomb spaghetti [__] B-Rabbit
yeah cause I'm from Orlando Florida you
know like I made it in New York and
became a man there but my perspective
even in New York as a New Yorker was as
a kid from Orlando who could not touch
it wow and that's never going to leave
that might be a personality thing right
that's why you see personality but also
probably good parents you know he
mentions dad on the restaurant which is
no punk yeah that's hard work like like
I hate when people are like oh shop has
a professional athlete's work ethic I'm
like no it no if you put me into
anything I I mean look at this bro you
were successful as a fighter and you're
successful most people don't have a
second career third career yeah whatever
you put me in that work ethic came from
you know an example of my dad my dad
worked his ass off so that's that's it
yeah it's not a race thing it's not a
yeah and
because I know people that do get they
got to do but they're working stupid or
they're just working the wrong direction
or they're not doing the work yeah yeah
but I always think of it as you start
with what you actually want and how
badly do you want it no I don't think
about that and then you go I do it and
you go well that's where there's certain
things I have to do to get there yeah
maybe that's kind of I don't think
you're wrong at all this is something
I've been thinking about because this
election coming up right yes and I'm
being I'm even seeing like all these
articles about Mass immigration to New
York and even New Yorkers who are the
most liberal and usually very open are
like immigration even they're like hey
hey yeah because now it's because it's a
problem for them now it's a problem for
within the problem like no it's all good
is it yeah and they're like yo pump the
brakes and I'm like yo everybody has to
reassess like these definitions that we
have like even I do really think that
when you see an immigrant that just got
here they're probably going to work a
lot harder than than someone who is here
yep because we're settled they want to
earn their Cape yeah yeah but we also
don't need to be scared of them and like
I think that we are We As Americans too
just have to be like yo we are there are
a lot of us that are hard workers like I
know a lot of second third generation
Americans that are super hard working
yep they have a fear that immigrants
will work harder than them and I'm like
bro don't be scared like everyone we
only got the same amount of hours in the
day I agree you know yep that's a good
point man you're obviously a liberal
I think I'm kind of like
yo I don't agree with the way liberals
try to get [__] done I think I agree
with their goals the term liberal has
changed like the definition liberal has
completely changed yeah of your liberal
you know you're woke up whoa whoa yeah I
think since 2020 it's gotten like really
you're even a little bit like if you're
even a little bit like say say you're
you you think well there's some ideas on
the on the left that I that make sense
that ideas on the right you can't do
that you got to be either all in over
here or all of them that just shows you
there's not a party that represents
really how Americans how polarized we
become in terms of like and it's a
gotcha thing I think there's a lot of
gotcha [__] on the internet ever since
Trump and I'm just like yo that's not
really that productive no people like
how's that moving America forward
because people just talk about it less
and less and they just go back to their
respective like Corners yeah so it's
like two teams now yeah it's like
Yankees Boston like you can like both
like no you can't but the greatest yeah
I like I like baseball in general yeah
but I think I still like most of my
family yeah but food is the one place
where it's like it kind of brings people
together it's like that's the 1A
political thing yeah it tastes really
good nobody Schultz was talking about
this he was talking to Dave Portnoy
about it because Dave loves food he you
know at his level you know is all the
money in the world and he was like the
one thing I just search for good food
now like that's my thing yeah and
schultzy was like you got to go to Tokyo
and Dave's like what he's like at the
best steak in my life in Tokyo at the
best pizza of my life best burger he's
like because they've mastered whatever
they wanted to do so now they've moved
on to food and it's our food yeah
because again they do it better than
this you think so again best pizza he
goes I'm from New York amazing whiskey
his best pizza I've ever had best burger
best steak I've ever had porno is like
no he's like I'm telling you Tokyo the
food they crush it they crush it I love
that you brought it up because they
really engineer it and you could
technically say this is the best
hamburger or this is the best thing they
mastered it yeah but you know what makes
me feel good when I see that is I'm like
yo I'd still rather be up in Peter
Luger's yes or I'd still rather be up in
Musso and Franks and that's what's kind
of cool about culture is you can study
it and you can engineer it and distill
it but if you weren't in the building
yeah and you're not living that life
that Vibe yeah
you're such an example of the American
expression though because like Chinese
immigrant parents grew up as like in in
Orlando New York and then food
culturally appropriating all different
foods steak adding a Chinese Fusion to
it having all this like it's this this
giant like Smorgasbord of culture it's a
Melting Pot like your food is literally
a Melting Pot it's America but it's
America yeah it's America and you're
like you're this poor Chinese kid
growing up on the streets
I'm saying he's American he's American
you're you're as American as it gets I'm
very American yo it's very funny is
because as a kid I was like not the most
I didn't have the most American Pride
because I felt left out I felt alienated
but yo as I've grown up it's cool
because I began to fit into my
generation yep and that the thing I like
like I said I'm very liberal and I think
most liberals don't come out and be like
yo I love America but after the pandemic
and I lived in Taiwan for a year I was
like yo I really love America because
I'm very proud of being born here and
living here there's something very
special here that if you go to any
country people are very curious about
like all my homies in Taiwan every
single day were constantly comparing and
contrasting their experience with my man
that's because we're so jaded here we
don't realize how good we have like
Brittany grinder went to Russia and
remember she was anti-america came back
was like America's the best oh my gosh
America oh man yeah it's like your
parents you don't appreciate your
parents until you're out on your own and
then you're like oh you're like oh damn
yeah you know and it doesn't mean I
forgive like everything like all the
fraud in this country and whatever I'm
just saying the people [__] with the
people here and I [__] with the amount
of diversity and like the things we're
allowed to do yeah what were you doing
in Taiwan uh I just went there because I
was like Americans are not going to wear
masks
because I'm from Florida and I was like
yo y'all do recognize Florida is
connected by land to every state you're
not going to get people in Florida to
cover their mouths not follow any rules
not never I was like the whole country
is gonna get infected so I bounced super
early because Taiwan and Asia there's a
culture of wearing the mask you guys
been doing forever forever it's in SARS
but the problem so it's with the irony
of that is that they didn't develop the
herd immunity in China that not Taiwan I
don't know but I know in mainland China
they had they have such a problem with
herd immunity so we got so exposed that
the later strains were really easy for
us to deal with I still would have
rather people wore mass and not get
bodied but in in Taiwan was there a
bunch of that everyone had mask on
everyone there was no covet there for
like basically 10 months and then one
dude came back and went to a whole house
they called a tea house and then spoke
at a rotary club like convention meeting
and got like 150 people sick and then it
spread everywhere that guy was stoned
yeah yeah
that guy had some special tea you're the
only person I know that sought like you
should have just came to LA and that was
weird
literally were like you're the only guy
I know that sought out more masks yeah
more power too I wanted more because
then we could like do stuff because we
kind of the first wave missed us yeah
and then people were hanging out in
clubs and going to restaurants like I
could live my whole life in Taiwan but
the crazy thing is even with that
freedom I missed America I came back to
get a vax and wear a mask and stay in
the house because I was like I Miss my
Homies I miss [__] buffalo wings yeah
like I miss walking down the street to
Leo's tacos like I can't eat Chinese
food again yeah you're like I love
Chinese food I found my limit it was
nine months you know you needed some you
need something else yo I was going to
Hooters just to like feel something
like just filming I was up in Texas
Roadhouse like damn these rolls are so
good yeah you know like so American yeah
like I didn't miss my like fancy Chef
[__] I was like yo the Food up in Texas
Roadhouse Texas Roadhouse man that's
wild yeah so is there any other plans
with as far as TV goes now advice is you
know advice yeah you know I actually I'm
doing a documentary on Vice on how like
the whole financial fall of the place
really and really correct me if I'm
wrong we don't have to get in the weeds
of it but it was all that with Dave
Smith right was his name Dave Smith
Shane Smith Shane Smith yeah Shane Smith
because it was like a toxic culture
right that's where it started yeah and
they also just never they didn't pay a
lot of people like I ended up having an
issue in the bankruptcy like how all the
writers have been fighting on strike for
residuals and things like that I owned
50 of the trademark on my show and I
owned 25 of the actual rights to the
footage in the show like as filmed and
aired on viceland these dudes never
accounted for my residuals and anytime
I'd ask they'd just send me a random
check and I'm like that's cool like I'm
definitely gonna keep your money but
yeah but can I get an accounting yeah
they're like oh we we you know no one's
actually kept track of it I'm like you
[__] run marathons on this yes
and like I'm friends with Shane I was
friends with him the whole time I never
once brought it up to him I was like I'm
gonna trust that your company will
handle this and do this the right way
but they never did and then they called
me a week before the bankruptcy and
we're like look we know we owe you this
much money we totally acknowledge it
we've been ducking it for years we'll
settle with you now and they made me an
offer for a number that was really low I
was like [__] it I'll take it because
you guys are banking yeah otherwise I'm
getting nothing otherwise it's nothing
go to the bankruptcy immediately it's
rejected and they're like oh are bad we
didn't really have the authority to make
that deal with you you need to deal with
the people now that bought the company
that's a that's a bummer and I I would
me and Shane live close to each other
and I would walk my son I have a 7 and
three old so my uh oldest son who's
seven at a time he was probably two or
three and every morning you'd walk
around the neighborhood every would
start our day walking I'd me and him
would always see each other he doesn't
have his dog we'd always chat he's
always cool I love and once that broke I
was like you should have paid me my
money yeah yeah for reals did he make
out did he make out well in the in this
oh yeah yeah yo if you look at this dude
like
his assets don't match up his contract
from Vice like the dots don't connect
you know what I'm saying but I'm gonna
save it for the documentary that's such
a bummer because that the World by the
balls man biceps amazing stuff but what
brought him down was it the financials
or was it I'm gonna need your 1750 at
AMC dog
it's great there's crazy stuff it's
because also it's like yo we worked so
hard for that company so many people not
just me a lot of my homies can't get
jobs because of how mismanaged that
company was even though they're
incredible artists yeah they're nothing
to do with it yeah people just don't
respect the work of people that came
from Vice and like there's a lot of
shoddy people in the upper management
category but when it comes to the people
that do the work like yo hire them
they're really good at what they do yep
like we almost sign wouldn't be
they're doing a vice right now is doing
a thing on on Rogan
um they're doing and I'm gonna go
interview with them vices yeah I'm going
to interview with them today wow to talk
about Joe Rogan because uh because I
talked to Joe and I was like you know
I'm
you want me to do this you know he's
like man you know can't hurt because
because I don't want if they're going to
interview about Joe I want somebody wait
is it it's Joan a good light I think so
well they're doing they're doing they're
doing nine people Hulk Hogan's one of
them uh Joe Rogan and they're doing an
expose on them not expose but they're
kind of like talking about people who
apparently can't be stopped regardless
right who just continue to grow and I
don't know what that means I know if I
had probably if I had to guess wouldn't
be as sympathetic to Joe Rogan as I
would be so I'm I'm just gonna throw my
hat in there because they asked me to oh
they're just going to edit the [__] out
of that wait they're gonna do a
documentary on Joe they're doing one of
the episodes devoted to Joe of a
documentary series then that's what
they're doing now like they go what
beyond Behind the mat or whatever they
do like the rest and what's the topic
well for me they wanted to interview me
about Joe because you know I've known
him for so long oh no what's the topic
of the series yeah like why people that
don't be canceled I don't know I don't
know but it's
it is people you can't be canceled so
the greatest podcasters of all time I
think it's something about regardless
the way the wins change some people seem
to endure oh that's what it is I think
it's more like American icons who kind
of like continue to be relevant
regardless of whatever happened do you
know who else is involved Hulk Hogan who
else I I there was there were a couple
names I just can't remember Hulk Hogan's
sick Hulk Hogan's I like Hulk Hogan me
too I've been re-watching the NWO fights
it's so good did you hear him on Rogan
oh yes
like I love the old ones it was great
yeah I like the old wrestlers yeah yeah
Hogan was great on there man yup are you
a sports fan yeah huge sports fan yeah I
think you're a New Yorker you're like
Knicks Giants what are we talking about
here I'm yo I'm all over because born in
DC so I was a commanders fan first and a
Georgetown basketball fan they were big
when we were kids huge because the
bullets were ass nobody was watching the
Bulls so we were like yo we watched the
Hoyas and then so Patrick Ewing went to
the Knicks so that's why I'm a Nick fan
that makes sense it's because of Patrick
and so I'm Nick's commanders and then
basically because of Goodwill Hunting
I'm a Red Sox yeah
I really like [__] really cool
hunting yeah and like but I'm honest
about my team he's hilarious yeah that's
a great movie though yeah and it's weird
like I'm a Wolverines fan because of
like the X-Men Wolverine I was just like
I don't have a bad college team that's a
terrible reason I like to I like
Wolverine the X-Men
at least they're good yeah right that's
good yeah they're flying it was a good
choice I'm very happy
my choice shout out to X-Men Yeah man
they let me know every single day yeah
of course like I don't miss my apartment
but I miss the city would you move back
out it's tough with kit with New York
like in like real New York where the
kids talk yeah I would if I had it if I
had my paper straight you know like
because New York at this age with the
kid is a rich man's game correct I I
don't want them living in like the
apartments I used to live in all ratchet
and [__] and like calling people to turn
the heat on like I paid a lot of rent
money but you still it's like the first
three days of winter you're like yo
homie turn the [__] heat off yeah
you're living right would you move
anywhere else besides New York
so many people from California moved to
Texas Nashville Florida you know Florida
I really love like I love Florida the
schools are [__] but I went to them
schools and I'm I'm all right you're all
right yeah
they'll figure it out they'll figure it
out it's actually I went to those
schools yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah
and so that that I would Florida I think
about the DC area but I don't think it I
think I need to be somewhere with a
little more action yeah so I think it's
Miami or LA to be honest Miami I feel
like you'd do well I love Miami yeah me
too
I love Miami I don't know how I would do
living there yeah well I'd be Hunter
about it yeah 100 100 try my card well
no no no I mean my dick sucked that
sounds like a good life yeah yeah you
ain't lying brother the pool
Miami's nuts best looking women in the
world am I crazy
because my girl likes the strip club so
it's like we just oh interesting it's
like cool be like that would be a hell
of a time yeah I like Miami all right
yeah I like the idea of you also with
your food it's a night town you got you
got a restaurant people come out yeah
there it also feels like a foreign
country because it's like half Cuba half
America yeah it feels foreign and also
the services foreign yeah even the
Starbucks oh these are all like
Dominican or Cuban Starbucks you're
there for 30 minutes I'm like if I don't
get my [__] coffee I love it all
there's no rush but I like it because
there's another industry besides
entertainment and like there's people
who just don't know what the [__] is
going on in our stupid entertainment
world that I love because you could be a
goon you could just like walk down the
street and spill coffee on your show go
through your day it's fine you have
coffee all over yourself here it's like
oh my God I have a meeting with
so-and-so oh my God the rat race out
here should probably put my adult diaper
on yeah
don't you feel that way we're all stuck
in this like thing where you've got to
be productive and you've got to be
working 16 hour days no matter what even
to survive but you think you think that
changes if you move to Montana I think
that there's certain hairs yeah we would
find some [__] to do
I love the work I would be chopping
[__] trees down but my thing is just
like dealing with the social [__] here
yeah stresses me out yeah I don't like
the like the social like putting that
working yeah I mean either me neither
yeah like somebody's gonna tell you
about how their reverse smoke seared
their steak
I'm also such a hater I'm a Big Green
Egg guy so I hate on the Traeger the
Traeger is good it's convenient yeah I
mean a guy all right Tim what do you got
I know I know so I'll do whatever you
tell me I'm I suffer from peer pressure
so so should I go green eggs
Traeger is good so tell me you hated it
bro yeah because I'm a dick like listen
to me I like the Big Green Egg because
I'm like it takes more skill you have to
control the flow of air and that's how
you get the temperature the Traeger you
just turn on you're like it's at 220.
you know what I mean but you like it
though you like it also you're not a
chef right yeah but you would do
whatever are you this way with cars
because he's because I like a Tesla
cause I can get in there and I just
drive it's like a computer I have to
think about it think about it this guy
likes
like yo I I like you know I went on like
eight or nine dates with my girl before
I hit I'm like I love this I love this
how many more [__] mazes are you
gonna make me run yeah crazy [__]
[__]
but like you like you just pull up you
know take the valet like I'm here you
know yeah dehydrated garlic flakes man
yeah exactly the Traeger is just like
guaranteed smash yeah you're gonna get
like it's a guarant that she's gonna put
out you want to work for it bro yo big
green you gotta work I gotta get in
there I gotta like [__] work from the
feet to the face you know what I'm
saying I mean your feet using the Big
Green Egg
are you eating feet no see he's not here
you don't eat your feet
Green Egg I think that's the best
analogy yet it's like if you want to
work for it Big Green Egg yup are you uh
are you is there any food you won't eat
you think it's gross
like we had Steve rinella in here and we
yeah he's a big hunter we said weirdest
thing you've eaten he said dog
yeah I don't know might want to lay low
for a minute you know I'm all for white
dudes saying they ate dog just to like
reverse the stereotypes
yeah yeah he was in Vietnam
he said he's in Vietnam and it was just
like that's what they do there he's like
it's just like obviously in America it's
frowned upon but it's just different
I'm sorry you know just people talk
about it cracks me up because since I'm
a kid you know people are just like yo
so like if I got close with the white
kid like the one question so like dude
your parents
you befriended me for six months to ask
this question
but no what's the weirdest [__] I have
eaten
damn will you eat like brains tongue I
don't eat that stuff honestly probably
my girl's foot coming out the Encore
Club because I think I spilled like
[__] Guy Fieri's tequila all over it
like lifted his foot so it's like a lime
and Tequila what the [__]
like my girl make a soup it has the
lining of the cow's stomach oh yeah I
worked too hard for us to eat right yeah
my fairy tequila foot tasted
yeah that [__] stinks though pickled
foot yeah yeah the Encore foot yeah damn
all right Jim what do you got
all right do you want to start with the
big news as far as celebrities
yeah celebrities so Taylor Swift and
Travis Kelsey this one's interesting so
be Travis Kelsey's the best tight end in
the league right and he's dating uh
Taylor Swift
yeah they've been seen together she came
to the game she was like this super you
know Wagga wife you know like the wag
she was like freaking out we scored a
touchdown it's interesting me because
because then he pushed the the Pfizer
shot anything Taylor so so it's
interesting I don't know what the play
is that interesting uh because she's
she's big into that and he had to turn
comments off because he's getting lit up
right like those type of dudes are shot
the the vaccine shot oh he was talking
about he did a commercial for it oh for
the vaccine yes and she's anti-vaxx no
she's super vags oh so it's weird it
just it's weird how it lines up oh like
it seems to me like it's almost fake and
here's what else is interesting but just
you know putting the the things together
here have you seen his ex-girlfriend no
she's so bad let's see and she's the
opposite Taylor she like has a wagon on
her like this but she's she'll tell us
long and Tall
yeah and people well people oh I
remember they posted a picture a video
of her walking down a Runway yeah and
they're like they're like damn that's
different food Travis fumbled the best
different food yeah
why is Rick Ross up in there too Rick
Ross up in there that's different food
too you know what Rick Ross Rick Ross
also some close-ups here though
oh no go hey go to
um who posted it uh who uh what's up
Will Compton post the Pfizer commercial
no not that that that thing's gay the uh
oh wow
from Akash Twitter because he retweek
and someone goes Kelsey fumbled the bag
and he goes yeah fumbled the bag by a
billion dollars so again if they get
together she might have a billion but he
had a billion and a flat ass like his
his ex is so bad so bad yeah it's all
this relationship is very beneficial for
both of them though yeah I feel like
energy sales went up 400 yeah this is a
good thing for sure I'm team Travis
Kelsey I'm happy for him I love it
because he's kind of like reverse
kardashianing this yes you know like I
think he's gonna come up off this
keeps you'll see the video oh there oh
see there it is go up Travis fumbled
this is his girl right now
that's his girl no no uh uh fan yeah
that is a big fan yeah I'm a fan
well booty yeah that's just more my
speed personally oh dude I saw her in
person yeah that's that's uh that'll
break your back right there in the best
of ways so he went from that to uh
interesting he's on a diet now yeah yeah
yeah God bless God bless he has to be
the fame thing right like he comes with
like obviously she's a
depend what you're into she's a stone
cold six with a flat ass right but it's
but it's it's absolutely I'm not gonna
comment on that right we're just gonna
pretend she's she's very pretty
her face cool right
that's cool still like not not our style
like pumpkin jack
her fans are so wild
I already got a movie
sir I'm not mad at that
she looks pretty good there bro
I did too that looks hilarious that's a
hilarious photo
this one she's on the table can I get
more close-ups of that chin don't type
in thick just type in Taylor Swift
nice try Bud yeah he's a Taylor Swift
fan okay very poor face is super pretty
yeah really I'm gonna say anything about
it she's sexy man
she's sexy she's that she got some meat
on her bones now I'm very happy with
that she put on yeah I'm happy I'm happy
you're pleading the fifth man it don't
matter what I think
oh man
yeah
I know what you mean we've seen her in
person and yeah I mean you you let me
pick you know I'd rather drive that yo
let's see what was Taylor Swift's export
because I feel like she always got like
wimpy boyfriends yeah she always has
like some pushovers so I'm like yo she
she got a real man right now he's all
man I've skeptical hippo eyes of this
relationship with the Pfizer the fish
she's
cool Jake chilling how cool but they're
all tiny these are yeah these are all
kind of like a certain type of manners
and tying tiny he's a big guy John is
not these are all nice guys these are
all really nice guys let's go to the
right too yeah we got Tim McGraw no
that's that's the song that she did oh
it's called Tim McGraw yeah so who are
the actual ex-boyfriends all these
except for Taylor Taylor is John Mayer
Tom Hiddleston he's like that actor like
50 Shades no one's no one on that list
is gonna hit her with the building like
Travis Kelsey no so I'm happy for Taylor
Swift you know maybe her music will get
better from this too you know you know
that Connor Kennedy
he's a
Michigan fan too Joe Jonas a little dude
yeah but these dudes is not hitting you
with the building no no no they not
eating that foot out the club no Travis
Kelsey's a hungry boy yes he's getting
in there he's not just throwing a dick
in a Traeger no no he's gonna [__]
work the yeah
you're just here hit me from online
you feel me yeah man I'm I'm happy to
see where this goes I mean yeah we'll
see he's an outlier I've never heard
that expression he's not hitting her
with the building you think it's real
love or what that's good I mean I didn't
think about it till now but
they might be dating but I see that how
they could benefit him for that I don't
know this is big in sports oh yeah
Kelsey's a smart dude feels very smart
you know him and his brother have a
great pod uh also whoever he comes up on
next is like this is kind of it's a
feather in his eyes so people like Akash
whatever you know is being like oh he
fumbled the bag like nah you playing
because you playing checkers dog yes
Travis Kelsey once you break into this
Echelon of woman so every morning
yo yeah there's there's 10 000 other
joints that want to be yeah if you're a
chick it's like hooking up with Brad
Pitt there's only one way to go 100
would you get that co-sign yep lateral
now every girl is going to want to
compete with Taylor Swift so they want
to be the next girl talked about yeah
bottom line and her tour did like a
billion dollars like if I know Leonardo
DiCaprio [__] him that's quality that's
quality yeah it's like a butcher it's
like oh this rest is really good Peter
lugers buys beef from me yo I'm in I'm
in yep I'm in yup that dude finds
premium [__] you're you're one of the
premium yeah Leo alumni yeah I'm in yeah
age 26 years I'm in yeah that's ivy
league box yeah you know we kicked him
out The League at 23 but yeah 26 27.
really does he [__] only with phenoms
oh yeah oh you know only baddies yeah
he's the discipline it's a brand name
yeah but the discipline it takes for
that guy at 50 to go through that that
long without Ever Getting falling into
the well they tried to a love trap all
done yeah like he's just like no I gotta
cut this off you're like damn you stayed
that solo for that long because yeah
it's kind of sad when you think about it
but yeah yeah I agree with you you're
super lonely I agree with you though
right and they're also 23. you ever
talked to 23 year old lately that's what
I'm saying he's probably just shut up
there is something to be said let me
read this question somebody's marrying
him having a kid yeah we haven't
factored in that part he may actually
connect with this woman
dude you're so right you're so right we
haven't thought about this sir
he really like her music yeah that's
just like impossible
do you listen to her music no yeah but
her as a person maybe he likes her as a
person
we never factored that in it's possible
yeah we really didn't
thank you for bringing us back to you
know what's real she just don't seem
that fun but like look he may really
like it yeah it might not be for us but
maybe they're like Souls so so Eddie
it's safe to say that if you had your
your pick of the people you could meet
the top three people she's not breaking
top three that's all no no no no no I
would yeah no no she might not break
300.
yeah oh man seems like a good kid though
uh this is big in sports B you won't
know any of these people but uh Damian
Lillard got traded to Milwaukee Bucks so
they have this is huge so they have the
freak Greek the freak Giannis and him
together they're still not gonna beat my
nuggets but this is big because he
wanted to go to Miami yeah all
indications said he's going to Miami I
want to go to Miami over Milwaukee he
did too with Jimmy Jimmy buckets with
Butler but now he's going to Milwaukee
so and this just got announced and so
what what is it uh so that he's just so
good in other words he's oh yeah he's
been playing in Portland they suck I
actually think Phoenix did the best in
this trade I think Phoenix got better
they've been trying to get rid of ayton
for a while yeah
chick I can't pronounce yeah nurkic and
then they got a bench now because like
Grayson that's what they needed a bench
for them yeah Nazir little he plays a
great defense yeah he plays three
positions like I think Phoenix Loki did
the best because what Milwaukee gets in
offense it loses in defense yeah trading
Drew holiday yep yep I like how Eddie
has a detailed knowledge of sports as
well so he's like no I'm just a regular
guy man yeah I got my law degree but I
was terrible and I like sports he's got
everything you do it's crazy this kid on
the streets from China
let's go back on the streets of Beijing
[__] Orlando from the dirty Street
Chinese mentality you're into sports too
you guys watch basketball and Tiananmen
you guys know what basketball is
I'd say you're very competitive I like
it yeah no I'm I'm I'm you know it's
funny I'm personally competitive with
myself yeah but it's funny like even
sparring right if I work somebody the
first two rounds I'll I'll just chill
out the third round like once I already
know what what do you mean Spar like
boxing just do boxing yeah yeah I box a
lot yeah you do yeah but uh at a church
Hill on the west side yeah I used to box
at a wild card Hollywood and then Wild
Card West and then it became Churchill
you're getting the ring and bang around
yeah spars man yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
fun did you know that about him yes you
did I trained with your boy Camacho
sometimes oh dope yeah really dope Chris
Camacho yeah I know Chris oh you know
Chris because I swear I used to box it
uh gloveworks oh that oh yeah yeah he
told me about that yep yeah he's great
yeah in fact Chris Camacho said
something great to me I would never warm
up I'd just start hitting yeah Chris
knows his [__] yeah play I played pro
football played with uh
the [__] was it uh I think the Chicago
Bears Arizona yeah Bears no I don't know
just go Um no I'm just saying I I'm
pretty sure it's Chicago okay and so
yeah I was like I would just start
hitting and he looks at me and he goes
just just hit and ride not warming up at
all that's cool and that was the
beginning of the problem all right yeah
I sparked Camacho one time and he
dropped me it was hilarious he's just
far too strong for me
super athletic super strong I mean he
fought professionally oh I forgot about
it but he dropped me it was pretty funny
so but with some Hill hooks
with these like [__] wide hooks but
Wild Card West is it it's it's no longer
there uh yeah they just renamed the name
that we named it Churchill yeah
Pete Berg yeah that's a nice chance he
still owns it I think so it's a great
chance
and our boy uh yeah the he teaches there
yeah yeah Chris used to it Frank Willow
over there oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know her dad's like
what's up you know what what's up
[__] I told you she's batshit crazy I
was trying to help her out in social
media you guys push so much this [__]
is free now [__] around with knives
it really is such a good lesson that
people have an opinion about [__] they
don't know about that's so funny you
don't know how in love Travis Kelsey is
yeah but we shoot our shot you would
just mouth off you're right even her
dogs are worried look at her yes I don't
want to play the sound too loud because
it's music you look like she's about to
Chef the dogs
this is a crate this is somebody who is
who is crying for him well she's
unfortunately not in her right mind this
is some this is real but then you had to
come out she's like the knives are fake
it's like girl you ain't fooling nobody
it's just a bummer man
so the sound tells you those are real
knives and one's pointed to like this
the blades pointed to her face she's
holding it like that and one's down and
then not together what's up she's just
not well no she's not dad's like I told
you dumb [__] yeah you're right and
they're like she's on Instagram she's
wearing a yellow dress that's a sign for
help dad's like what no we have nothing
to do with this so later on people
notice that she after the video she has
a bandage on her arm and then there's
like a cut on her leg right here
yes
that one's more like a bruise but it is
so weird yeah so people are really
worried about it I wonder why she has
doesn't have a relationship with her
kids she obviously she's not there
immensely for sure she went crazy didn't
it when Ben yama's security guard like
stiff Armory slapped her yeah I was like
[__] you better back up crazy ass she
blamed him too but you can see it I'm
sorry you can see it in her eyes man
yeah it's just not there and the dad's
just like hold you I don't even care
anymore I wonder what happened because
it like I mean it's probably around when
she shaved her head but something left
the building yes yeah yes that all that
Fame and whatever she was massive I
remember though when she was like
complaining about the amount of
Paparazzi right that was like so much
this was when none of us knew this and
she was at the height of her Fame and
she was dealing with all this stuff and
my my wife at the time was working at a
photography studio and
and so she pulled into the studio in a
convertible
yeah like you you you've been
complaining and you're driving around a
convertible and my wife my wife at the
time went there's something very off
because if she was trying to hide from
the paparazzi she wouldn't be riding
around in a convertible so there was
already a disconnect it's just a weird
bird people I don't think people are
made to be that famous like Bieber thank
God he's made it I mean I think he has
some mental issues but human beings
aren't made to be that famous crazy you
only want to get fly so high before you
start you know do you think she went
crazy and that's why she lost her kids
and do you think how much you never know
I mean how much was it the fame or just
she's just like you must have been
pretty bad because the judge was like
yeah we'll leave the kids with Kevin
Federline yeah I feel for her man like
you can just tell she's having a rough
time like something broke in there she
just keeps [__] and hooking up with
her personal trainers she does yeah her
boyfriend now her last guy was a
personal trainer whoever's the next
personal trainer is like hell yeah
I still got it hell yeah I'm about to
marry this but then but then God got to
go from abstracts to [__] married so
my buddy went on a date with her
and
the whole time literally like they go on
a date full time
um
the height of her Fame
you know before yeah
and literally my buddy was eating dinner
with her the whole time and she was she
was on her phone like this the whole
time
oh she just wasn't into him your buddy
little boy no here's what's great she's
on the phone with him all the time so
he's like this this is the strangest
thing even the waiter was like you want
something else he's like yeah let's get
the check and then she goes I'll take
care I got it he's like okay so she pays
for the check and he's like I'll see you
later the whole time and then he gets a
call from her friend who says uh Britney
really liked you and she wants to go out
with you again
and he was like I'm good weird yeah so I
knew she was batshit crazy when she wore
all denim to the MTV Awards it was fly
though
the matching I was like the other both
batshit crazy yeah when you matched it I
like that I like it you like magic you
like crazy yeah I like I like when
couples step out crazy like that I feel
you yeah this is this is fly
this is I can't that's it
look at a young Justin Timberlake by the
way see she's all there here like yes
you know the brain is I knew the ways
were coming though when I saw that it's
true though look at her eyes you can see
there's like life In Her Eyes even in a
still photographed or something that
one's a little woggy on the right yeah
but right now dude she's got Justin to
break her [__] I think she just went
crazy Bubba I think she's she's too
famous
yeah even Justin was like [__] this or
maybe something happened in her brain
man it's like Amy Winehouse Amy
Winehouse before she killed herself they
would blame it on drugs Amy Winehouse
was they they saw her at a gas station
and she was just outside uh twirling you
know kind of walking in a circle the
difference between her and Brittany
Amy's a massive drug addict massive yeah
that's a big difference but she she was
also they think so the the interesting
thing is they said is are people like
that crazy and they're trying to
self-medicate like sometimes you try to
regulate your own brain with substances
because nothing else is working
so I don't know man I don't [__] know
I think we're gonna fight in 20 years
we'll be looking at this going oh all
she needed was this or you know you
think I think so I think mental illness
is going to be something well it's still
such a mystery it's such a mystery and I
think we'll look back at it and when we
say you wouldn't you'll never use the
word crazy again it'll be like it'll be
like
he was crazy yeah yeah you can't no I
don't know it is really wild that one
day like something you can just snap
like that makes me really appreciate
life and also to realize like don't take
[__] too seriously yeah because we
didn't snap it anymore you could really
[__] snap I knew a woman whose
daughter went crazy and she it was so
heartbreaking because she went crazy she
didn't know what to do and she would
just go she just went crazy and she
would just wander the streets like one
of these people sometimes your brain
snaps man yeah we're possessed
by a demon what else you got Jen all
right so I'm sure you guys have seen
this already but Joe Biden flubbing
yellow Cool J's name oh he [__] his
name he goes out whatever and then calls
him a boy that's so bad so he was
honored at Congressional Black Caucus
foundation's annual legislative on the
[__] yeah and I'll just play the clip
for you
two of the Great
the greatest Cool J
[Applause]
by the way that boy's got he got man's
got biceps bigger than my thighs I think
he's been
and it runs all right both of you thank
you I knew MC light wow
Uncle Mike you know you're uh you're all
here to listen to the New Edition
Mike vivints 40 years producing music
anyway he's he's not out there either
bro he I was giving these long-ass names
they'll like protect the guy don't have
them ride bikes don't have them go
upstairs don't have him try and
pronounce rappers names I just think
it's [__] that we need to hello J
cool that's the [__] I would do yeah we
all know what we're voting for are these
people's cabinets you know what I mean I
don't know why we keep up this act of
like all right propped this fool up bro
he's the president like this guy is a
[__] flesh bag I agree it's straight
up just like put him out there just
who's [__] Karl Rove right now yeah
whoever's running this [__] please
[__] stand they just need to protect
them be like all right we don't want any
cameras around when he's getting on Air
Force One we clearly struggles with
stairs yeah we ain't riding no bikes
we're not pronouncing these weird
rappers names for him you see him do the
Asian names bro he's terrible this guy
is not functional who did this to him I
would struggle with Asian names I have a
splash of CT way more sharp than he is
they don't think he's gonna run for a uh
second term they think last minute it's
going to be gas and Gavin Newsom I've
heard a lot of people Michelle Obama
I don't think so I think a Gavin Newsom
is is positioning himself he's going to
debate Ron DeSantis he's he's taken on
this gender thing the next thing is
going to be crime he stopped the gender
thing because it was that was the big
black guy I know yeah I think you're
right man I think the thing is is like
what we like what is happening with the
presidency is they're more figureheads
yes and they're more just
representations of what Americans want
our leader to look like and sound like
and be it's the cast it's the squad
who's yeah it's the cabinet and the
party that are pulling the strings
Biden's Weekend at Bernie's he's just
yeah yeah he's straight up burning
Michelle Obama would be a really good
representative yeah she can represent us
to other countries like she could do a
lot of [__] yeah but the cabinet would
be the ones making the decision Michelle
could do so I get that big ass bash
Bros a non-starter I don't think
Michelle oh nakama's not happening but
but they they they I I do think that
what they're gonna do RFK could be
anything
controversial two two minutes I would
vote for Cheryl I would vote for his
wife Cheryl over him you know like
Cheryl from the curb yeah all that stuff
I heard her on tigerbelly and I was like
bro you don't need RFK you should run
like I vote for you yeah
I like any of the options to be honest I
vote for Larry David yeah I would vote
for Larry Larry David would actually do
something because it would drive him
crazy like this is annoying [__] I might
vote for them that magic mind is fire
bro yeah right it's honestly good like
they advertise on the Pod but that
shit's really [__] there you go I
drank it before I came here you did yeah
yeah dude we'll get you every day we'll
get you some some samples no no they
send it
the magic mind yeah we'll give you some
samples man just a four different China
yeah dog with you if you put this up is
that some famous chef I gotta gotta get
some magic man I love it bro I [__]
love it but thank you I'll take your
magic I know you can't get this stuff no
you don't like mine I put Garlic flakes
in it I love it yeah
dehydrated garlic there's one more I'm
gonna remember that 40 minutes to 240.
once you start drinking this stuff
no favorite part oh interesting
interesting I haven't heard of that so
delicious
by the way delicious is Japanese that's
racist
bro all right
all right there's like a one with a
shooting or just called a car
[Laughter]
what was it okay you went with us one
with a shooting or just like a cool car
uh both all right so the shooting one
will first car better be [__] cool
dude you're probably gonna hate it so
this isn't a Jack In The Box and this is
in 2021 but the footage was just
released what so
this is fine so dude a dude picked up
his pregnant wife and they had like a
six-year-old kid in the in his truck and
then they did an order then he notices
there was no curly fries that is
frustrating so it came back around and
then this is what happened oh this
[__] he shot some parent he shot a
family no no the woman that actually
this is in Texas and the woman she
starts getting pissed off
right he's like hey not gonna put the
curly in the fries
should you say what
oh
yeah those hand gestures are never good
Manchester [__]
a lot of hand gestures they do this
ketchup packets and then so the employee
tries to lock that safety window yeah
and then she turns around oh she got it
on her face too oh that's frustrating
bro so she unlocks it here and she has
her gun out right you got a gun is she
fires she fired multiple shots at them
and there's a kid in the clock
and I see this I'm like I don't need to
be here no like I would stay my ass in
Uruguay she's going to jail where was
that at Texas oh and she she's going to
jail right no so this is what's weird it
says Ford that's who that's who she was
convicted in court of aggravated assault
with deadly weapon and her probation
concluded in June so she looks like she
was patient for this that's why I had to
look it up firing at a family because
and they were upset they didn't get
curly fries this is jail she gotta go to
jail jail we can't have those people
walking the streets so I looked this up
on also you're the one that [__] this
up not curling them fries so this is
what it says for aggravated assault up
to one year in county jail or fine of 4
000 if no one gets shot no one actually
gets killed and two or twenty two to
twenty years in prison and or are fine
of 10 grand so I guess you can get away
with it if wow you don't actually kill
the person
shoot at you
good luck
because that's true damn she's shot and
they had a kid in the car yeah a kid and
a pregnant woman this is what degree of
assault is this is that first I saw the
deadly first degree felony
state
so Texas WoW shark attack my buddy no
these are older ones I'm trying to get
the car but if here it is so okay so
check this out this is the the new Prius
slammed in Japan oh wow don't tell me
this doesn't look good for a place those
ribs are wow tasty this looks like the
old Acura Integrity yeah dude no you
don't get this card you said you like to
work for something so you guys keep out
of this this is my car that's pretty
dope right all right you could drive to
drop Prius
that's a Prius yeah yeah they put the
body kit on it and that's all they did
they just put a body kit on buy kit
slammed it yeah
Prius that is [__] hilarious pretty
cool
um you would love this page friend yeah
that seemed pretty dope it's called hype
whip so you can have to keep putting
Priuses on there but yeah that's cool
they pinned it at that SRT V10 Viper
sick the Daytona body that's filthy
yeah this guy right here that's dope
Thanks Jen you're welcome so end on a
happy note I guess hell yeah we don't
end on that lady man
no just you know our pod magic my I be
promoting magic mine hell yeah our pods
separate bedrooms you know
good luck with the kiddo man that's big
nothing better from
thank you for having me guys we're in
Vegas this weekend uh skank Fest Brian
Count Me Together Friday Saturday only
Comedy Zone October 6th and 7 Greensboro
North Carolina get your tickets let's go
and I will be in Iowa October 13th and
14th Niagara Falls almost sold out two
two shows one Friday one Saturday that's
a casino in Niagara Falls Chicago in
December I got a bunch of stuff uh
coming up all right guys I'm heading to
Sacramento uh shooting some cool content
with the truck well stay tuned all right
Eddie we love you man thank you thank
you man thank you guys